Last time we heard about the uh,
some medical considerations regarding
stereochemistry and we're going to just
start today with a little bit about legal
considerations about Stereo Chemistry.
Uh, first, uh, uh,
the doctor gave a disclosure
last time about her connections,
so I'll do the same thing.
I've served as a scientific consultant
or expert witness to a number of farms,
pharmaceutical companies including Asi,
which is how I knew about that. Seven,
three, eight, nine,
I take Lipitor and served as an expert
witness for a generic competitor in a
case involving the validity of a
Canadian lip atar patent by Pfizer.
And my only connection to Astrazeneca
and a members all his is an occasional
consumer of [inaudible] sec.
Okay.
This book here is very heavy.
It's about the stereochemistry of
organic compounds and interestingly,
it's from 1994. So it's, it's
all, it's less than 15 years old.
It's still the Bible and only eight pages
of it are about biological properties.
And just one of those pages had anything
to do with legal things which had to do
incidentally with cocaine. It turned out
that somebody was on trial for cocaine.
And the, the defense had
the idea that the, uh,
that the prosecution did not tested the
cocaine to see which he auntie Maria.
It was as to whether
it was, it was, uh, uh,
artifice might've been artificial
because the Ian antitumor of cocaine,
there's no law against.
It also wouldn't work.
But anyhow,
they hadn't tested it so they thought
they could get their client off.
I didn't actually look up the case
to see whether they got off or not,
but that's an interesting
stereo chemical application.
But one that made a big difference was
the court rejecting a suit about Nexium
marketing. We saw last time and
you did a problem for today about,
uh,
about Nexium and whether the advertising
seemed convincing to you or fair for
that matter. There was a big, uh,
suit about that and this in 2005 was a
news report about that a federal court in
Delaware dismissed the class action
lawsuit alleging Astrazeneca had misled,
had,
had misleading marketing of Nexium and
thus added billions to healthcare costs.
And the district court judge,
Sue Robinson rejected the suit brought
by the Pennsylvania employee benefit
trust fund on behalf of entities that
foot the bill in health care plans
according to the health
plan paying organizations.
The big difference between the two drugs
is not effectiveness but advertising.
So you presumably looked at some of this
and have your own opinion about that by
selling doctors and patients on the
idea that patented Nexium is better than
prior lasek which face
generic competition,
Astrazeneca was able to preserve
billions in sales. So for example,
the year Nexium was introduced
the, their, their marketing,
their advertising budget was $260 million.
And in 2005 it had declined
slightly to $226 million,
but the sales were five point $8 billion.
So the advertising was negligible
compared to the cost of advertising.
Judge Robinson said the courts should
defer to the u s FDA in weighing the
differences between drugs and that
since the FDA cleared nexiums label,
the lawsuit could not stand.
So That's interesting.
And shows the importance of the FDA.
Okay. Back to chemistry now, uh,
in order to market Nexium,
the singling anti Mer
Astro Zenica had the,
of course prepare it as a
single land in antitumor,
which meant either resolution.
So separation of the right and the left
handed forms or else preparation of only
the one form the s uh,
members.
All I noticed that the
doctor said Isa met resolved.
Maybe they all pronounce it that way,
but the reason they got the names
because it's ass, right? So I say yes,
a map result. Uh, so how are
you going to do it? Resolution.
You could do a posture
conglomorate kind of thing.
You could make temporary dietary
immerse and separate them perhaps by
crystallization or you could destroy
wanting antitumor react the Ras and mate
with the resolved chiral reagent that
would react with only one or maybe a
catalyst that would catalyze the
destruction of only one, like an enzyme.
Or You could do it nature's way and
prepare only wanting auntie Marie either
from a resolved chiral starting
material or using a resolved reagent or
catalyst. And they tried,
they tried all of these.
So let's a look at it first.
A resolution of a map
result by chromatography.
So they had uh, Silico, it's what you
use probably in your chromatography,
but they coated it with something
that was a singly Nan tumor.
Now how did they get something solid
that was a singly Nancy where that they
could coat it with, they
got it from nature. It was
cellulose, Tris, fennel car,
Bama wheel cellulose.
And they did this in 1990 when they were
looking forward to the time that they'd
lose patent protection
on the Ras Rasamayi.
So there's cellulose and fennel, ISO, Cya,
Nate thing with two double
bonds in a row there. Now, uh,
what would make you think fennel
isocyanate reactive the reagent.
See any functional groups there?
Any ideas? Okay. Carbon double bond. Good.
And how about the cellulose?
What's going to make it reactive?
Rick? What makes cellulose
reactive? Any functional groups?
Sole unshared payers on oxygen.
Okay,
so none shared pair on oxygen
could attack the carbon yield.
Now it could attack either the CEO
or the CN double bond. And in fact,
we've seen this before.
This,
remember is how urea got
made from ammonia and,
and uh, and the, and
the corresponding acid.
This is just the fennel derivative of
that asset. So it does the same thing.
And in fact you can do it with all the
ohs in the group. So you put that, uh,
that car bammo wheel group as
it's called on all the oxygen.
So that is the chiral stuff that was on
the solid that the chromatography was
conducted with. Now they weren't
able to get very much. They did,
they did six injections in chromatography
and were able to get three milligrams
of the dextro rotatory and four milligrams
of the Livo rotatory stuff separated
by the rate at which they would go
through this chiral column. Now,
that wasn't enough for any kind
of human testing or anything.
You need 20 milligrams. Remember
for a human dose for just one dose.
But what they could do was
measure how fast [inaudible] was,
because obviously if the stuff
rast summized immediately
it would be useless to
have a single enantiomers.
So they found out that that the half
life for [inaudible] was an hour at 75
degrees,
which they then extrapolated to what it
would be at a body temperature to be a
hundred hours. So plenty of time, it's
not going to randomize just spontaneously.
So at least that was not a trouble.
So they,
so this very first quick way of resolving
it allowed them to see that it was
maybe worthwhile continuing.
Okay.
Then they tried reversible formation
of a crystal and man delete Esther.
Now that red stuff there is mandelic acid,
which is a natural substance.
So you have that as the pure s enantiomers
and now you want to react that with
uh, with the OMAP resolve with
the receipt we can map result.
But there you do it with
an intermediate compound,
formaldehyde such that the Formaldehyde,
the carbon eel group gets attacked
from both sides one of the time by the
nitrogen on the Ameb Rizal and the oxygen
on Mandelic acid to put ch two group
between them.
And we'll talk about that a lot,
that kind of thing when we get onto
the chemistry of aldehydes and ketones.
But anyhow, they could do that. Now they
have what? What Stereo? What's the stairs?
They have two things.
What's their stereo chemical relationship?
Because they had received
me come and resolve,
they've reacted it with s mandelic acid.
What are the two that you got two
compounds. What's their relationship?
Russell?
Their dietary immersed.
So they're different so you can
crystallize them apart. Okay.
So they did that and then the important
thing was that it's a reversible
reaction so they could go back again
adding water and get the result back after
the separation. And now they have
both the r and the s versions of that,
both the d and the l or the Dexter
rotatory in the Livo rotatory forms of a
members all in separate bottles and
now they have hundreds of milligrams.
So it's not enough to
do a large scale test,
but they can do some biological testing.
And with it where they found that the
ar was four times as active as the s in
rats that they studied. But Lo and
behold, when they got into humans,
it turned out it was reversed,
that the s was more active than the are.
So that's why the drug is SMF resolved.
Okay?
But that's that you're not going
to do this to make enough to, uh,
to sell to the public,
especially because you don't want to
throw away half the material you make,
both because you're polluting
the environment, uh,
and because you're wasting the money
you've put into making it. So there's a,
they developed a chiral catalyst,
uh,
involving titanium.
So there's a titanium bond bounded to,
to,
uh, to four alcohols are actually one
of them bridges to another titanium.
But anyhow, you can do something
called Lig and exchange. So one of the,
so the electrons in the
bond go onto the oxygen.
So you have our oh minus and
the plus you've broken the bond.
Now that goes away and a different one
can come in a different alcohol and form
a new bond.
So that exchanges the ligands by
losing one and putting on another one.
Okay?
Now you can do that trick
with Dai Ethel tartrate.
So two of the oxygens,
the alcohol,
oxygen's of tartaric acid can exchange
for two of the alcohols that are on the
titanium. And you get this,
this compound of titanium.
Now what you really want is the titanium.
That's what's the catalyst.
So you can lose another aro
minus and you get this Tei plus,
and now it's when the Talus begins
because you bring in a per oxy compound,
a hydro peroxide. So instead of an
alcohol, there are two oxygens there.
And that can do the same trick
and combined with the titanium.
So you have this compound,
but now you have different functional
group there you have the o bond and what
makes the OBOD reactive.
We've seen this before, Kevin,
and what is the low luma?
Right?
So sigma star is going to
be reactive there, okay?
And you could bring in a sulfur,
right with its unshared
payers and they'll react,
make a bond, break a bond, right?
So you get the sulfur attached to the
oxygen and it's s plus since it's used its
electrons to make that new bond,
uh,
now that thing can come off the same way.
The compound above it did the Aro came
off the the sulfur compound can come off.
And that's the sulfoxide.
And remember that's the important
group in the SMS spurs all.
That's what sets things
going. Okay, so we've got it.
And now that compound on the lower left,
the titanium compound is the same
as the one on the upper right.
So we've made a cycle.
Okay?
So that means we could look at the
cycle this way, a catalytic cycle.
We bring in our oh minus,
it combines with the little machine.
Then s comes in and Aro minus comes out
and then s double bond o comes out and
you get the catalysts back again.
Start at the top and go.
So you go round and round and round
and round. And every time you have the,
the peroxide come in,
the sulfide come in,
the Aro minus comes out
and the so comes out.
So essentially the r o gives one of its,
owes the redwood to the sulfur.
Right? But it's catalyzed by this.
Now why is it important for their purposes
that this thing be involved in Qatar?
Alesis we looked last time that you
can put an oxygen on sulfur just with
peroxide.
You don't need the catalyst to do that.
Although it's faster with the catalyst.
Did they do it just to gain speed
or could you see something else?
What's special about the catalyst?
Lucas part? It's one in antitumor, right?
It's a chiral oxidizing agent.
The peroxide alone would
have been an oxidizing agent,
could have done the trick,
but the Chiral oxidizing agent means
that it will discriminate between the two
hands of the product.
Right?
It could attack one of
the unshared pairs here
or it could attack the other and those
are Ian Antia Mers of one another.
But when it's combined with this
thing that has tartaric acid on,
which makes it chiral and have one hand,
then those are diastema
immerse one of the tacks.
This one or when this one
does the attacking. Right.
So they won't be 50 50 unfortunately
it was 50 50 it just happened to be the
same rate. So did they give up? No,
they started fiddling and one thing they
did was to add dye Eissa propyl ethyl
amine. Why? Who knows, right?
But they discovered that what you do
that then you get what's called 94%
enantiomers excess. That means
the desire dean, Nancy homer is,
they're at a 96,
97% and there's 3% of
the ragging antitumor,
right? So there's an excess of 94%
of the Ena, Auntie Marie you want.
So now all you do is crystallize
it and it gets purified.
You get rid of the 3% and
you have the stuff you want.
Now you can sell it to the
public as Nexium. So that's the,
that's the way you do it
practically, right? When you
want to make a lot of stuff,
you make just one.
Okay?
So that's what we're going to
say about a configuration. Uh,
and now we have one C to go.
We'd talked about composition of
course from the time of Lavoie,
ca about constitution from the
time of Cooper and [inaudible],
Calculi, uh, those,
but then there are distinctions
based on this bonding model.
Note that constitution is already
involving the bonding model,
but something beyond constitution
is how things are arranged in space.
So configuration is obviously also a
question of the model that you make in for
bonding and con formation, which is
the sea we haven't talked about yet.
And those last two are stereo isomers
because they have to do with arrangement
in space. Which constitution
as you remember it doesn't.
So you could, the difference between
configuration and confirmation,
both of which have to do with arrangement
in space is that the configuration you
have to break bonds to go for
one and I isomer to another.
And in the uh,
con formation,
you just rotate about single bonds
to get from one isomer. Other.
And in general it's hard to break
bonds and easier to rotate bonds.
So typically configurational isomers
lasts longer than conformational isomers
but not always.
There could be special cases.
Now all things that you call isomers
represent local energy minimis.
So the molecule can sit there at that
geometry and of course it has to be
vibrating at least zero point vibration.
So the atoms are moving,
but they're in a, well, they stay in the
same relative locations more or less.
Right?
They vibrate in there,
but then they can get out of that well
and go to a completely different well and
vibrate there.
So not all the different
phases of vibration are
considered different molecules.
That would be way too much to call
those all isomers of one another.
Those are all one isomer.
And these are all another isomer.
But there's some barrier to
get from one to the other.
So you can have one or the other.
And the barriers are typically higher
for configuration and lower for
confirmation.
Okay.
Now we've seen that in 19th century,
the stereo chemistry was qualitative.
It was a question of counting
isomers not measuring something,
but just counting how many isomers
you can get. Very qualitative, right?
But Khan formation,
which didn't come along until later,
which involves rotational isomerism about
single bonds is much more subtle and
it requires quantitative
thought about equilibria rates.
And Energy's not just this
qualitative counting of isomers.
So notice that this is,
that con formational analysis came
relatively late to the timeline.
We're talking about all the other stuff
we're talking about happened before.
Most of the other stuff.
Uh,
with respect to structure
happened before 1900,
but it was only in 1950 that
confirmational analysis began.
And then, uh, uh,
25 years later that people started doing
significant what's called molecular
mechanics modeling,
treating molecules as if
they were springs and so on.
And we'll talk about that a
little bit later. So remember,
there you are and we can
trace your lineage back to PD.
Bartlett at Harvard, who was my phd
supervisor and his phd supervisor,
JB Conant.
Now those guys were involved in a
special flavor of organic chemistry,
which influences you,
it's called physical organic chemistry.
It's interested in not so much in
making new compounds as in why compounds
behave the way they do.
So what you've suffered through this
semester is because of these guys,
right? We talk much more about why
things work, how bonding works,
how to recognize a functional group than
we do with memorizing reactions that
will get you from here to
there. Okay. So Conant was, was,
was one of the founders of this discipline
because he did phd with two advisors,
one of whom was a physical chemist
and one was an organic chemist.
So if we go back a little bit here,
you see the blue,
the organic chemist was Kohler,
whom we've talked about.
And the red was tw Richards,
the physical chemist who
himself studied with Ville Helm,
Austin called who together with Vantiff
and to rainiest these three guys here,
Vantiff last of all an erroneous.
Those are the guys who founded
physical chemistry as a discipline.
Okay? So, uh,
so we have a lot more physical chemistry
in this course than you'd normally
would in an elementary
organic course. Uh, now,
uh, if you go a little bit
further in the family tree,
you get GN Lewis as well.
When we've of course talked about
now in the late 19th century when these
guys were founding physical chemistry,
organic chemists focused their
efforts on molecular structure,
on these things having to
do with configuration and,
and enantiomers and so on.
But physical chemists focused on energy
sometimes to the exclusion of structure.
In fact, asked of all, oh, I forgot to
bring his book. I was going to bring,
but I can to show you,
but I have a page from it here.
He wrote lots and lots of books on.
First of all to is like, you know,
you're four great Kevin uncle,
grandfather or something.
This principles of chemistry,
which he gave the, uh,
not too modest title and introduction
to all chemical textbooks.
So this is why if you read it,
then you were ready to read
any other chemical textbooks.
So it was a general view in
19 seven and on page four 21,
there's a very long footnote. And if you
look at a little bit of this footnote,
it says Dalton who developed the law
of combining weights on the basis of an
hypothesis he had proposed about the
composition of matter from Adams at first
took hydrogen as unity since it had the
smallest atomic weight that is combining
weight.
And so there's the word Adam,
and that's the only place in 554 pages
of this book that the Word Adam occurs.
It's in the subordinate clause of
a footnote, because at this time,
asked of all, didn't believe in atoms.
He believed that philosophically,
since you couldn't see him,
you shouldn't talk about them.
So you should do things
that you can deal with.
And energy was such a thing he thought.
So physical chemists,
these guys who founded physical
chemistry focused on, of course,
Vantiff is interesting because he's the
guy that had the idea of the tetrahedral
carbon. So he didn't sign off on
this together with Austin Oswald,
but Oswald was much more influential.
He had a much bigger school of,
of uh, students. And so, uh, he was,
he was only two years later that he
finally accepted the existence of atoms.
So I'm just drawing you the contrast
between what organic chemists we're
thinking about and what physical
chemists were and that now,
to deal with confirmation, we have to
become a little physical chemist to, uh,
to, uh, to, to see the
influence of energy.
So here's the dedication of
sterling chemistry lab in April,
1923 and there is a group
of people that will look at,
and all of these guys here,
we're students of Austin Bald. So
he had a very broad influence. Uh,
the one there is tw Richards got the
first American Nobel prize in Chemistry.
Okay. Andy, he remember is, is, uh,
is your something grandfather.
Okay. So then, uh,
done in the next guy where there's a guy
from Canada, guy from Britain and the,
the uh, guy on the left, there was a
student of Richard, so a grand student of,
of Austin Ball with his cigars.
He always had,
and this guy is wilder band Croft,
who was at Cornell and who
founded and owned for that matter,
the Journal of Physical Chemistry.
And he wrote an obituary of Austin Bald,
uh, in 1933 in which he said, asked,
followed Skift for
leadership showed itself.
And the way his pupils regarded him
all throughout, all through their,
they usually believe Twat Ostfeld said,
even when they knew he was not right.
Okay. And no doubt Adams where what he
had in mind that Oswald didn't believe in
atoms, but as students still
believed in atoms. Okay,
but they all believed in energy. Now,
did anybody walk past here this morning?
You recognize this place? Okay,
you take a different path.
Okay, but have you noticed
what's off on the left there?
Here's stood the house
of Josiah Willard Gibbs,
class of 1858 professor
of mathematical physics.
So Yale has a really special
connection to, to energy.
There's Gibbs as a, as a
freshman, uh, and here,
here he is in,
in later life he spent his whole life
here at Yale except for one year he went
to Germany.
So physical chemists were and still are
quantitative about equilibrium constants
and rate constants.
So big K is an equilibrium constant.
Small K is a rate constant
and they're related to energy.
So you can call energy. He or if
you're, you're more particular,
you can call it h for
[inaudible] or g for Gibbs.
Free Energy and entropy gets into the
argument as we'll see in a few lectures.
So energy determines what can
happen at equilibrium. That is,
if you have this stuff,
is it possible spontaneously to go to
this stuff if you have forever and ever
for it to happen? Is it conceivable
that this stuff will go to this stuff?
It can only happen if it's
downhill and energy in free energy.
Okay. And the equilibrium
constant is determined by,
is related to energy in this way.
And here's something that's really
handy and you'll impress a subsequent
teachers and your roommates and
everyone else, if you remember this,
that if you know the change in
energy and kilocalories per mole,
you can say what the equilibrium constant
is cause it's 10 to the minus three
fourths of whatever that is.
So suppose the difference between this
and this is four kilocalories per mole.
What will the equilibrium constant B,
yeah,
it'll be 1,010 to the
three fourths of of four,
right? Three. Four. So four is three.
10 to the third is a thousand so the
equilibrium constants gotta be a thousand.
Now, whether it's a thousand
or one over a thousand,
depends on which way you're going.
But obviously it's going
to favor the one down hill.
So you have to keep your thinking
cap on to get the right direction.
But 10 to the minus three fourths of Delta
h or tend to the plus 10 to the minus
three fourths, uh, is the way to do it.
Okay. But you can also say
something about how fast it will go.
This is just whether it's conceivable
that it will go. The big guy,
the little Kay says how fast because
rates, this is an approximation.
This isn't a written on the
tablets by the angel or someone.
But for practical purposes,
for our purposes,
the rate in seconds,
that is how many per second is 10
to the 13th so that's very fast.
10 to the 13th per second.
But then it gets cut down by
how big the energy barrier is.
You have to get across.
And the cutting down is exactly the same
kind of thing you have in the big k 10
to the minus Delta h.
So you can again,
that that energy is
called activation energy.
It's how high the barrier is
that you have to get over.
And you can use the same
trick of the three fourths.
So it's the rate constant is 10 to the
13th minus three fourths of whatever the
energy.
So if you have a four,
suppose you had a four kilocalories of
energy barrier you had to get across was
you had a 40 kilo calorie energy barrier,
you had to get across 40 kilo
calorie energy barrier, right?
How fast would the rate constant?
B?
Yeah.
Becky, why don't you help me? So
the barrier is 40 kilocalories.
Okay. That you have to get across. So
now how am I going to plug that in here?
Okay, so three fourths of 40
I need, right? So what's that?
30 30.
Okay,
so it's 10 to the 13 minus 30 okay,
what's 13 minus 30
okay,
so it's 10 to the minus 27 per second.
Do you think that's very fast?
10 to the minus 27 that's
a pretty small number,
right?
So forget spontaneously at
room temperature going over,
uh, going over a barrier
of 40 kilocalories per mole
for practical purposes.
But you have this tea here. So if you
increase the absolute temperature,
then you make that for bidding factor
smaller and smaller and smaller.
Up in the exponent. So if you heat it
up, you could make the reaction go. Okay,
so Eddie, yeah, that's really,
that's really helpful to remember
this three fourths trick. Okay.
Now,
confirmation involves rotational
isomerization about single bonds.
So the question is,
how free is single bond rotation?
Paterno said it wasn't free at all.
I can count isomers that way I can have
this isomer and I can have this isomer
and I can have this
isomer, right. For cat,
for purposes of counting. But
van Hoff says, no, don't count.
Isomers like that because why?
Why shouldn't you account
isomers like that?
Because they rotate too easy, right?
It's like that in his picture. Right?
So you shouldn't count this and
this and this and this. Okay.
Now there are different kinds of models.
Something like these,
and some of them you can rotate
easily, but not others. Right?
Which one's realistic, right? Or
I mean, this one you can rotate.
It's just not easy to rotate, right?
It sticks. Right? Or this one,
remember that Fisher used,
which is good because you can
bend it for his purposes, right?
For drawing two dimensional
Fisher projections.
But forget rotating that right.
It could vibrate, but it can't.
You can't rotate it. It'll always
come back, right? So the question is,
which model is right?
Can you rotate or can't you rotate?
And how hard is it to rotate?
Because that's going to determine
how fast these things will be. Okay?
Now notice that all that both of these
authors drew their pictures with a
confirmation which we call eclipsed.
Now eclipsed means these means this,
that the ones on the top or right
over ones on the bottom, okay.
And the same is true in Van
Hoff's Tetrahedron, right?
Right above the others.
Obviously you could rotate, uh,
60 degrees on the top and
everything would be staggered,
not directly above.
Okay?
Notice incidentally that from the exam,
we looked at the molecule of the week
for last week from the American Chemical
Society and notice how it's
drawn, right? It also is eclipsed.
This redwood here is directly opposite.
This red one here,
this acid group is directly
opposite that hydrogen,
and this has group directly opposite that
hydrogen, it's eclipse, right? And here.
This CO2 is directly above that CO2.
It's eclipsed right now you
need notation and, and uh,
and names to talk about these things.
And this,
the projection that was invented for
this purpose was invented by someone who
sat in the seat that some of you
are sitting in, I don't know which,
maybe he's probably in the course of,
of his undergraduate years
and also is getting his phd,
probably sat in most of the seats
in here or many of them anyhow,
but his name was Melvin Newman.
You see,
he graduated from Yale in 29 he got his
phd in 32 and then he went to Ohio state
and he invented a way of
drawing confirmations on paper.
So there are two carbons in the,
the convention is that for the Newman
projection that you sight down the carbon
carbon bond.
So I'm going to show this,
the rotation around this central bond.
Okay.
So I look right along that bond and
there's one carbon in front and one carbon
behind and each of them has
three things on it. Okay.
So the one behind here has three hydrogens
and the one in front hides the one
behind,
okay?
But it has three other groups on it to
everybody. See how he's doing this, that,
that shows this why it chose it
without the methyl groups here. Okay?
Any calls that staggered,
right?
But you could also have the be right
on top of one another like this,
right?
And that's called eclipsed.
And that's the way it was shown on the
previous slide by Paterno, by van Hoff,
and by the acs operative who
made the molecule of the week.
Okay.
Now that does,
that's not so convenient because
you can't see the stuff in back.
So sometimes people turn
it a little bit that way,
or sometimes they turn
it a little bit that way.
By which they don't mean
that it's not eclipsed,
they just mean I want to be able to
show both things right now that's very
cumbersome.
And the reason you don't mind that it's
cumbersome is that things are never
eclipsed.
They're always staggered.
So all those previous pictures were wrong,
including the molecule the week.
Because confirmations tend to
be staggered, not eclipsed.
Okay. But anyhow, you can
draw them in this way. Okay.
And that's just the conventional way of
drawing something that's eclipse because
it's, as you can see, it's not
truly a 100% eclipsed. Okay. Now,
when you have substituents
on those things,
you can give different names to different
phases of rotation. For example,
they could be exactly opposite
one another like that,
which if this were a double bond,
you would call trans or e.
Right?
But for a single bond,
you look at it with a Newman projection
like this, and it's called Auntie,
right?
Or you can have it rotated like
this and be what's called Gauche.
And I've never found out why
it's called Gauche. Right?
But notice something about that.
Is this,
is AMT chiral is that confirmation
chiral or is it super imposable on?
Is there a mirror? Right?
There's a mirror right here,
right. So it's its own mere
image. How about Gauche?
Is it chiral? Is there a mirror
here? There's a twofold access here.
If I rotate like this,
if I had you close your
eyes and did that rotation,
you couldn't tell whether with
whether I had rotated or not. Right?
It's like a propeller.
But if I take another one like this and
make the mirror image of this Gauche win
like this
here,
right? This is a mirror
image everybody see? Right?
But I can't superimpose them, right?
If I superimpose the back three,
the front ones are not right.
So these are chiral.
So with respect to go, shh,
we have enantiomers right?
That one as well. And one of them we
call minus and the other we call plus.
Okay.
And now if you have the analog for
eclipsed is that you can have something
that's fully eclipse,
right?
That where the special groups are right
on top of one another or it can be like
that. Right? But again,
so and that can be one way or the
other. Again, it's twisted like,
like a propeller would be,
and these are again,
cumbersome things to draw
with Newman projection,
but you don't worry about there being
cumbersome because you don't have to draw
them usually because
they're not energy minima.
They're not isomers. There are barriers
between going from one to another.
Okay. But again, those
would be minus and plus.
And if you want to be really pedantic
and meet in a committee of the pure of
pure and applied chemistry people,
the IUP AAC,
and decide precisely what you're
going to call different things,
then you get together and you scratch
your head and for different rotations of
the thing in back with
respect to the thing in front,
you have these different pedantic names.
Sin Perry Planar is,
is is the one that we called fully eclipse
and you can have anticline UL and Sin
Clientele and sin,
Perry planar and plus and minus and so on.
But you never do that really, but it's
there if you need it. Okay, so there's,
there's,
there's a notation,
Newman projection and there's
a nomenclature which could
be sort of simple like
on the previous slide or very complicated
like this that allows you to discuss
these things to draw and discuss them now,
but here's the practical question
is the threefold barrier.
So if you have ethane like this,
right,
and you rotate this,
the energy will go up and down.
If the,
the energies will be different
for different angles of rotation.
But obviously there's a
certain symmetry that this,
if it's all hydrogens will be the same
energy as this will be the same energy as
this and for the eclipse this will be the
same as this will be the same as this.
Okay, so there's a three fold
barrier. Now the question is to,
there are two questions.
How big is the barrier?
So are we going to be able to have
isomers and what's the energy minimum?
Now let's just suppose together
with Vantiff and Paterno
and the person who made
the molecule of the week
that the lowest energy,
if we plot energy versus
phase of rotation here,
that the lowest energy is zero degrees.
That's fully eclipse like this. Okay,
that's zero degrees and now we'll start
turning it and the energy may go up when
we go to a staggered and then down
and then up, down, up, down. Right,
and then you're back where you started
once you've gone through three 60 degrees
or is there a big barrier,
right? Is the barrier smaller,
big? Now, how can you tell?
Here's an interesting thing,
a way to tell,
right that if there is a big barrier,
then the things are going
to be quantized in it.
The energies are being quantized, but
the energy is, if the barrier is very,
very small,
then almost any energy you have is above
the barrier and so it's not quantized.
Remember when you get above a barrier,
you can have energy, any energy you want.
It's only when the thing is
bonded on both sides, that the,
that the wave function has to
come down and reach zero. Okay?
So if the barrier is big,
the energy will only be certain amounts.
But if the energy is very small,
you can have any energy you want.
And that you can tell that is
in fact how it was discovered,
how big the barrier for rotation was,
was by measuring something, having
to do with energy, with heat.
Okay. And here's a, so the question is,
is the energy quantized
in this triple minimum?
We've talked about double minimum. This
is actually a triple minimum. Okay.
So you,
they measured in 1936 the
absorption of heat by ethane,
uh, going down to very, very low
temperature. This starts at a 150 Kelvin,
but I think they went further than that.
So there's a thing called entropy and
we'll talk about that in different terms a
little bit in a, in a week or two
after vacation. Okay. Vacation.
Okay. So there's a thing
called heat capacity CP,
which is how much heat you absorb.
So entropy is defined by people who do
thermodynamics in this way that you sum
up or integrate starting from Zero Kelvin.
Remember Calvin,
all the way up to whatever
temperature you interested in,
you sum up how much
heat is being absorbed.
So CP times temperature,
that's how much heat is being absorbed
at each temperature as you go up,
as you raise the temperature
more and more heat gets absorbed.
But you always divide it by the
temperature as you go up. So if you,
if you absorb heat at
very low temperature,
that makes a much bigger difference
than absorbing the same heat at high
temperature in this
quantity called entropy.
So don't worry about it except
by this definition for now,
and this is very technical and not so
very important to what we're doing.
So don't get tied up in knots about it.
But anyhow,
if you have larger quantized spacings,
then less heat gets absorbed.
And I'll show you that on the next slide.
And the heat that gets absorbed gets
absorbed at a higher temperature,
right?
So both those factors mean
that the entropy at any
given temperature is going to
be smaller because you've absorbed
less stuff in the numerator and you've
absorbed at a higher temperature so you
have a bigger denominator for all these
contributions. Okay, so the
results in 1936 where this,
if you're interested in what the
entropy of ethane is at at 298 Kelvin,
it turns out experimentally, that's
what they did out at Berkeley. They,
they found it was 54.8 plus or minus 0.2
entropy units and then they calculated
how that, how, how,
how high that would be for different
heights of this threefold barrier in the
quantum nation that's involved.
And what they saw was that
if the barrier were zero,
that number instead of 54.8 should be
56.4 if the barrier were 0.3 it should be
56.3 if the barrier is 3.1 it should be
54.6 which is within experimental error
of the experiment,
right?
So that showed that the barrier was
about three kilocalories per mole.
So it wasn't totally free rotation,
it was just pretty fast.
So suppose the barrier had been four
kilocalories per mole instead of three.
Just suppose that were for how fast,
what would the rate
constant B for the rotation.
So the barrier is four kilocalories
per mole that you have to get over.
How do I deal with that,
Sam?
It's this, there's a trick, right?
10 to the minus three quarters
centers, four is three.
Okay,
so it's going to be tender.
There's going to be a minus three up
in the numerator up in the exponent.
And what else is going to be an exponent?
Remember for a rate,
10 to the 13th so it's 10
to the 13th minus three.
So it's 10 to the 10
to the 10th per second.
So we'd take 10 to the minus
10 seconds for it to rotate.
That's pretty darn easy at room
temperature, right? Pretty easy,
but not perfectly free and enough to
make this difference in the entropy.
Now let me just see what time it is.
Okay, we have time to do this. Okay,
so we're now going to use that
big k equilibrium constant.
So suppose we have something that has
this Roger say that has a barrier of such
that the spacing between successive
levels is one kilocalories per mole.
Suppose it's a harmonic oscillator.
We already did that.
The lowest zero point level you had
to have that energy and then one kilo
calorie above that one kilo
calorie one kilocalories.
Now what we're going to
do is see how much energy,
extra energy above zero point
is there at equilibrium,
right? At any given temperature. So, uh,
so we have some stuff
that's at equilibrium.
There's going to be stuff
that has no extra energy,
zero point, a certain amount,
but there'll be a certain amount that
has one kilocalories per mole that's in
that first level.
Now how do I know how much is in
that first level at equilibrium?
How do I know the ratio of what's
in the top to what's in the bottom?
If the spacing is one kilocalories per
mole, is there a way of doing that?
You don't have to do the numbers,
but tell me what formula you would
use to get the equilibrium constant.
Caitlin, do you remember, Sophie,
how do you get the Big k?
How does it relate to energy?
Anybody remember we already
did the hard one. Eric.
10 to the minus three fourths of one.
Okay. That's at room temperature.
It's different at other temperatures.
Okay,
so so we know how much there's going to
be that what fraction of the stuff of
the stuff that's here is going
to be one kilocalories up.
It's going to be 10 to the minus
three fourths right of of this.
So something like a 10th of it,
right?
10 to the minus one would be a 10th okay.
And then there'll be stuff here and the
amount here relative to the amount here
that this is what we're
doing so that that ratio,
the ratio of zero to one is going to
be the same as the ratio of one to two
because that one is one kilo calorie
above this one and the same for the third
to the second or the fourth to the third.
So then we can sum all these up there
knowing the ratios and figure out what
percentage there is of each of these.
And it turns out that that tend to divide.
The three fourths is 5.6 so there's going
to be 5.6 times as much here as there
is here.
5.6 times as much here as there is here.
5.6 times as much here as there is
here and if you translate that into
percentages it will be that there's 81.9%
here and one over 5.6 14.8% there and
two seven 2.7 0.5% and 0.1% but of course
this stuff added only what this 14%
added only one kilocalories per mole.
This one added to this one added three,
this one added four so you sum all
those up and you get how much energy,
how much heat was absorbed. This didn't
absorb anything. It's still in the lowest.
This absorbed a certain amount,
14.8 right 0.148 and then twice that
0.2 0.027 and so on so you can sum it up
and see how much heat would have been
absorbed by the time you get out there.
Now if the spacing had
been very much smaller,
if the spacing had been
0.025 kilocalories per mole,
then we would have made the,
how much is there of this?
That's at the lowest level.
How much has one unit 0.025 how
much has 0.0 5.075 and so on.
And we do exactly the same trick,
although of course you need
to a spreadsheet to do this
with cause it's tedious,
right?
But you would get this and you think
you absorb more heat if you have smaller
steps.
And now there's 4.2% here and 0.8%
at exactly one kilocalories per mole.
But you have a lot of others in here.
So 59% of the population is between,
is halfway out to the one and then a 33%
is more or less one and a 6.6% is like
that and so on.
So anyhow,
you'll absorb more heat and you
absorb it at lower temperature too,
right?
So both those things build up the entropy.
So that one absorbs 364 kilocalories.
Mole,
more not kilo calories,
small calories,
364 more than the other one.
And that is what gives
that entropy difference.
Okay.
So that's how people knew that there was
a barrier to rotation was by measuring
heat capacity.
Uh,
so we'll stop here and next time we'll
address the question of whether the,
now we know what the barrier is, but we
don't know what the low energy forum is,
whether it's eclipse,
they're staggered.